malno compressor station near germany's
eastern border
much of the gas hissing through these
pipes comes from russia powering
businesses heating homes
plant spokesperson nicola ragensberger
says it's a critical supply
this plant is particularly important for
europe she tells me the gas reaches
millions of households through germany
and further into the european gas
network and all the while it flows in
from the west money heads back the other
way
every single day europe pays russia
hundreds of millions of pounds for its
oil and gas in fact since the invasion
began germany alone has paid a total of
nearly seven and a half billion pounds
effectively financing the war in ukraine
everyone agrees that eventually that has
to stop but the question now is how fast
and on whose terms
[Music]
we do have problems if the energy will
be cut off or would be cut off
we are dead we can't produce any more
above all thomas droisiker fears a
sudden disruption in supply if vladimir
putin turns off the gas as he has done
elsewhere rationing could follow and his
plastic moldings company would be done
for
as long as that doesn't happen he can
take the pain of rising energy prices we
were founded in 1929 which was the
biggest economic crisis
and we survived world war ii
and some other crises in in the last
decades
and i think there will be a life after
after putin or after this crisis
100
his employees can't afford to be as
confident
just uh
with what is going on prices of coursing
of living is getting getting high not
only energy
food prices oil everything petrol
the situation getting hard
that's what germany's government is
focused on it fears a recession of its
heavy reliance on russian gas is reduced
too quickly
even the climate change envoy agrees
if getting off russian fossil fuels is
so critical why can't germany do it
faster
germany is moving as fast as we possibly
can to get off fossil fuels you're
seeing that in the phase out of coal
you're seeing that with moving forward
on oil and we're moving as fast as we
can on gas but we need to be doing that
in a balanced way that also
makes sure that germany is a stable and
balanced place
according to government critics these
issues were largely avoidable
the problem is that germany is the only
industrialized country in the world that
is simultaneously phasing out nuclear
power and coal power we have simply
narrowed the supply of energy too much
and are now in the situation where we
are dependent
and some are warning that even if europe
could agree on a russian gas embargo it
might not even work
we need to remind ourselves the russian
central bank still has 300 billion in
foreign reserves a lot of that in the
form of gold in the seller so this can
be spent which means a short-term impact
on the war is relatively unlikely
no good options apparently available as
germany's moral and economic dilemma
continues and the war in ukraine rumbles
on
hannah thomas peter sky news in berlin